[Music]
foreign
hello my name is Colin Rendell and I'm a
professor at Duke University in the
department of statistical science and
I've been teaching data science with r
for a decade now and I've been teaching
shiny specifically to our students since
2015. this year at posit conf I'm
teaching a one-day workshop on
developing and deploying shiny
dashboards
um here are three reasons why you should
consider taking this Workshop
the first reason is to level up your
shiny skills this is the workshop that
is designed for our users who are
already have some basic experience with
shiny and are looking to improve their
existing skills we'll briefly review
basic shiny Concepts around reactivity
and app development but we'll quickly
expand beyond that into topics like
Dynamic user interfaces modularization
and customization
um with that said the second reason you
should take this is to learn how to
customize your existing shiny apps and
make them look unique
um one of the most powerful aspects of
shiny is that the app interface is just
a web page therefore pretty much
anything that you can do with HTML you
can do with shiny and so in that vein
what we will be discussing is various
dashboard interfaces for shiny there's a
lot of options out there we'll talk
about how they're different how they're
similar and how they're implemented and
once you understand how they're
implemented that gives you an idea about
how you then can customize them yourself
um and so doing will also be touching on
the larger shiny extension ecosystem and
how you can use that to further
customize your app and simplify your own
code and then finally we'll also be
talking about options for theming so in
particular if you're working on a shiny
app for a client how you can customize
your app to match your clients branding
or other kinds of preferences for how it
looks finally we'll also have a segment
discussing about deploying your shiny
apps
um we'll have a detailed discussion of
what options are available for you to do
this we'll touch on
the whole range of options including
things like shinyapps.io posit connect
and even options around self-hosting it
what the limitations of each of these
are what the advantages are and so on
and so forth if any of this sounds
interesting to you I encourage you to go
to posit.com conference to find more
details about this workshop and all the
other workshops that are being offered
during the conference that's also where
you'll be able to enroll in this and any
of the other available workshops I look
forward to seeing you all in Chicago in
September
foreign